in the manner of death of gabrielle
lenora petito
we find the cause and manner to be
caused death by strangulation and manner
is homicide we now know how gabby petito
died but several questions remain
unanswered in the story most importantly
the whereabouts of gabby's fiance brian
laundry as far as the time of death
we are estimating three to four weeks
from the time that
the body was found in a press conference
on tuesday teton county coroner dr brent
blue shared new findings about gabby's
death
after a detailed investigation by our
forensic pathologist our anthropologist
and local law enforcement
with assistance from the fbi the teton
county coroner's office is following the
following verdict in the manner of death
of gabrielle menorah petito
we find the cause and manner to be
caused death by strangulation and manner
is homicide meanwhile some details were
not addressed in the press conference
including whether gabby's body had
bruising or if her body had been buried
or left above ground by wyoming state
statute
only the cause and manner of death are
released we are only involved in the
investigation of the
body of the deceased so
who committed the homicide is really to
be determined by law enforcement
following the coroner's report laundry's
attorney released this statement gabby
potito's death at such a young age is a
tragedy while brian laundry is currently
charged with the unauthorized use of a
debit card belonging to gabby brian is
only considered a person of interest in
relation to gabby petito's demise the
attorney also reiterated that his client
is still missing you believe he's hiding
somewhere i do
why do you believe that this is a coward
flat out we want to know the truth
that's gabby's parents speaking with dr
phil last week opening up about their
suspicion that brian's family knows more
than they let on
do you think they know where he is now i
do believe they know a lot more
information than
putting out there
gabby and brian spent this past summer
traveling across the country documenting
their trip on social media brian
returned to his parents florida home
with the couple's van but without gabby
who was officially reported missing on
september 11th days later gabby's body
was found near grand teton national park
and
despite gabby's parents calling and
calling they won't tell gabby's family
she's not there and that she's missing
et spoke with legal expert nancy grace
about the case and she called out the
laundry family many people are pointing
the finger at brian laundry's parents
just like gabby's family is
after they are confronted by the fbi
they admit
that brian laundry actually left one day
earlier
for the carlton reserve which i think is
alive
that gives him another day's head start
he took gabby's van all the way across
the country he never never had a
suicidal ideation he never showed
remorse during that whole time he used
his dead girlfriend's debit cards for
what a drive-thru at mcdonald's
no i don't think that now he's suddenly
home with mommy and daddy and off to god
only knows where that he's overcome with
remorse because his track record tells
me otherwise